[Music]
sean in minneapolis hi sean how are you
hey i'm good how are you guys doing good
relief to hear your voice what's up
yeah i'm good um
so
i have recently picked up your total
money makeover from a used bookstore i'm
really glad that i did i saw a crazy
looking guy cutting up a credit card and
i thought what is this about um and i
just i totally dove in and i am dead set
on paying off all of my debts and i
can't look forward uh anymore to the day
where i can come on stage and get my
debt free screen with my girlfriend
anyway so good for you
my question is
my question is about the budget um and
more specifically
the
things that you budget for that could
change on a month-to-month basis
uh so like doing your bills and your
mortgage is relatively easy because they
don't really change much at all if at
all
but i'm kind of struggling with the idea
of like how much money should we be
setting aside for
uh groceries or clothing um things like
that
i guess like do you guys go off of like
a percentage or this like a flat amount
per person in the family what do you
recommend have you is this your first
time doing a budget
i've always had
like a
a half
but
budget where
like i said i'm doing the easier things
um but it wasn't until i started using
the every dollar free app that i really
started so yeah
i'll tell you how i did it and that i
wasn't really doing it 100
yeah i'll tell you how i did it when i
got started budgeting and i think this
is how we teach it dave correct me if
i'm wrong but um what i did for my very
first budget is i looked at my bank
statement for the past three months to
see what was the average that i had been
spending on groceries or that type of
thing and it's not because i always
needed to spend that but it gave me some
type of range so i'm not setting some
ridiculously
uh unrealistic number and then i come up
the range okay i typically spend about
this much and then you can kind of
stretch yourself to a goal from there um
you know for for some of those things
that can fluctuate but because you do a
budget every month so for example um i
it's august right now and um i just went
back to school shopping for my kids they
needed some new clothes they've outgrown
some of the clothes and so on so i know
august is going to be a higher clothing
month before the month yeah you can
predict that right right before the
month i know august is going to be a
back-to-school shopping month whereas um
you know in july i'm not going shopping
for clothes for example so you will sit
down before the month begins every
single month and it's a it's a it's the
best guess you can based on past track
record and in line with your goals of
what you want to spend and where you're
going did am i saying that right you did
perfectly okay perfectly and stuff like
even utilities will change from month to
month like we're in tennessee and so
it's really hot in the summers and so
our air conditioning bill our
electricity bill is higher in the winter
i heat my home with natural gas and so
my electric bill is fairly low but my
natural gas bill goes up in the winter
and so i can predict that december's gas
bill is going to be different than
june's
okay as an example right and i can look
at last year's i can look at last year's
and guess pretty close to what it's
going to be and on that kind of thing
you want to guess a little high
so you say okay you know last year's gas
bill was i don't know make it up 235 or
whatever okay well just go ahead and
round that to 250 and put that in there
and that way you got yourself a little
wiggle room if something comes up and um
and that's how you do it and then the
last piece is
that a lot of people including my wife
uses the envelope system
and we don't use it for everything but
for a few things you mentioned groceries
uh by the way a hint on groceries is
whatever you think you spend on
groceries before you actually start
living on a budget you're wrong it's
more
yes okay
if you think you spend 500 it's probably
more like 800. if you think you spent
800 it might be 1200 and i'm not talking
about restaurants i'm talking about
groceries only
separate groceries and restaurants apart
because restaurants are entertainment
and groceries are food
yes you get food at a restaurant but
most of what you pay for is the
experience of having someone else cook
it for you
and uh clean it and all that stuff so
um you know go that route with this and
you'll be much much better off now so
the envelopes all we do with that is we
say okay for the month i think we're
going to spend 800 and put 800 cash in
an envelope and write food on the
outside that envelope don't buy anything
out of that envelope except food and
don't buy any food except out of that
envelope no cheating and so you are
using cash that does two things one is
when that envelope gets empty you know
you've run out of money
and there's a little catch mechanism
there it's empty versus if you've got
plastic or even writing checks in the
old days you know you could just keep
going there was no there was nothing to
stop you and go uh oh
we've over spent the budget yeah and you
could do that for the back to school
close you could have a back to school
close envelope for august and say that's
it because
you know you got little boys going back
and that little boy stuff's cute is it
little girl stuff just about it's good i
mean it's fun dressing them up yeah you
know and you could go crazy in there
easy enough and blow your amount and not
and have all kinds of rationalizations
and justifications but if you're looking
in that envelope at real hundred dollar
bills real 50 bills and they are leaving
it slows your butt down because you feel
it yeah i got a question about the
envelopes and maybe you've talked about
this and i've just missed it have you
talked at all about
the so envelopes
have this like built-in discipline right
like because it's visual you can see it
you know since the pandemic dave
everybody has so much so much online
shopping yeah and amazon
man add to cart is so easy yeah
well i mean if you're if you're having
to transfer that discipline to if you're
not if you're if you're going to buy
online you're not using the envelope and
i used to i'll tell you one that's
changed over the years when we first
started teaching this
30 years ago you did not pay for
gasoline at the pump
yeah you walked inside to pay for it
right i do remember that old school
uh-huh i remember that and so
i used to carry and teach to carry a
gasoline
envelope with cash to pay cash for your
gas and then when it goes up five
dollars a gallon you're like pissed at
the president right
and so um that kind of stuff right so
now but i haven't paid with
we haven't had a gas envelope at the ram
season years we pay with a debit card
right like you're doing online right at
the at the pump but so you've still got
to budget that and keep track of it and
you've got to have some way and the
every dollar budgeting app will let you
know but you've got you've got to
categorize each of those expenditures
yeah and when they pop on your debit
card especially if you've got the
premium edition where it's what
automatically logs and all that right
then you go okay drag and drop drag and
drop you're dragging that expense over
into the food category at amazon
dragging a food expense over there oh
and we've got some cash over here then
you look up and go crap we just went 500
bucks over this is not gonna work i
can't do this well every dollar makes it
so fun and makes it so easy to do but
you're right because you might have a
grocery budget or clothing budget and
you spend the majority of your monthly
expenses out of that envelope or out of
that category in cash but then there's a
percentage you get amazon fresh or that
you get a couple clothing items off off
online and you've got to be able to
reconcile that this is all coming from
the same budget line item and it will
drop down when you start dropping those
things over that are that are
transactions like you're talking about
but it's it's it's important to pay
attention to because you've got things
coming out of different places and if
you're not careful that add to card will
get you man not that i know anything
about that add to cart yeah i don't even
know what that is so you can add stuff
they suggest people like you buy things
like this
and then you add to the cart it's it's
like it's not even that dave it's like
sometimes you're just having a day and
you're like i don't know i just need to
add some things to my cart just any cart
oh the cart wasn't already had anything
in it no this is just brand new this is
just generally online shopping dave this
is not listen i guarantee you all the
women listing are going like yeah i mean
they make like doormat just sitting
around bored and going i need to buy
crap i mean
it's a real thing
they make they make dorm mats that say
like amazon man please hide the boxes
from us
online shopping is a real no i know i
knew i know but i mean i didn't know but
i know oh my god
like like you'll see on instagram a meme
that says it's an ad to cart kind of
kind of day
okay so now you know retail therapy
online style 100 i'm glad i can help
them today boredom spending yes
it's a thing well i'd just be ashamed if
i were you i would just be ashamed i
don't not only do you know about it but
but you've done it oh my god i'd just be
ashamed if i were you i felt no shame
maybe i should i just don't i feel no
shame i'll do what i want
uh i'm christy right that's it